warum machen wir das was sie machen und
wie kaffee warum machen wir es kurz das
was sie machen kreise sind absolut aber
warum will sie so sehr sagt wieso
können sie die gesetze der physik
scheinbar aufheben ich habe mich
jahrelang ich an dieses thema getraut
weil ich einfach keine gute erklärung
gefunden haben niemand konnte erklären
jeweils gut erklären brummkreisel das
was sie machen machen trotzdem heute
also der versuch und spektakuläre
bilder wirklich zum science fiction
übrigens eine show mit preisen am
schluss gibt es etwas zu gewinnen
herzlich willkommen
erst mal etwas ganz anderes zwei
millionen user klickt man einen neuen
rekord gebrochen wachsenden wahnsinn
das hätte ich anfang des jahres den
kanal auf tägliche videos umgestellt
habe nie geglaubt das liegt zum dass man
erreicht jetzt bin ich mal danke sagen
also es war ein riesen dankeschön an
euch ihr seid der hammer ich bin total
begeistert wer hier mitmacht diskutiert
und euch inspirieren lassen und likes
auf die video setzt wenn ich dann in den
kommentaren lesen dass ihr euch
gipfelsieg als leistungskurs in china
weil euch ging es um dazu motiviert hat
dann geht mir das rohöl oder wenn
klicks um - im unterricht angewählt
werden dann ist das einfach gern und das
motiviert mich jeden tag weiter zu
machen es ist auch eine verrückte zeit
nahezu täglich werden neue erkenntnisse
veröffentlicht forschungsarbeiten
brauchen nicht mehr jahre publiziert zu
werden sondern manchmal nur tage und es
gibt themen die sind so absolut spannend
wie schwarze löcher oder die suche nach
außerirdischem leben dass ich einfach
ständig nach den neuesten erkenntnissen
ihre und die welt daran teilhaben lassen
möchte denn viele wissenschaftliche
publikationen waffen einfach nicht die
relevanz oder können wir nicht
erklären ich will das hier tun und
mache deshalb noch ewig weiter 2008 habe
ich mit glück zum angefangen und fixum
ist damit einer der absolut ältesten
deutschen youtube kanäle die immer noch
programm machen also 2009 an dann
regelmäßig angefangen videos zu machen
und weiter geht es mit eurer
unterstützung vielen dank an euch
vielen dank an christian möller der die
videos ganz toll schneidet und wieder
kroymann der das sehr lange zeit gemacht
hat und an marius soll sehr sehr lang
die skripte korrigiert und geschrieben
hat ich suche übrigen wieder einen
neuen praktikanten der die video
ausleihe wer also interesse hat einfach
an bewerbung achten punkt net schreiben
ich freue mich über zahlreiche
bewerbungen habe ich seit mitte januar
die text wirklich wieder alle selbst
also los geht's mit warum machen fidget
villa darf was sie machen
wer ein in die hand nimmt und bewegt der
märkte sofort wir haben ein seltsames
eigenleben und umso schneller sich
drehen desto welt wird dass die achse um
diesen sich drehen scheint wie von
geisterhand gesteuert werden und diese
geisterhand erlaubt ihre tags also ich
kann den finger gerade mal drehen oder
hier auf dem finger wagen fährt aber
andere youtuber können
wichtige tricks mit dem kätzchen und
sind nur wegen dieser geist möglich
aber woher kommt diese geisterhand
es ist wie immer ganz einfach trägheit
stellt euch einen stein vor den ihr
schmeißt er fliegt unbeirrbar dahin
wohin gewinn geschmissen wurde er
verfügt über einen beharrungsvermögen
eine trägheit sondern die richtung
wechseln muss kraft aufgewendet werden
ist ja logisch warum sollte er das auch
ohne kraft man hat ja energie
reingesteckt er mit der in diese
richtung fliegt nicht in der andere das
gilt übrigens für alle in bewegung
autozüge flüge oder ihr wächst ihr
kennt das wenn ein auto in die kurve
geht ihr werdet war sie in die
entgegengesetzte richtung also in die
alte richtung gedrückt weil euer
körper ja weiter in der alten richtung
fahren will die verträge
man greife ist das genauso nur dass hier
zahlreiche steine um eine achse greifen
wenn ihre richtung geändert werden muss
kraft aufgewendet werden dementsprechend
spürt man eine gegenkraft also dieses
beharrungsvermögen dass er selbst im
auto in einer kurve spürt wenn ihr die
richtung geführt die ausrichtung der
drehachse bankkreise verändert werden
sollte hat sind greifen ihrer lage im
raum absolut stabil und umso schneller
will sich drehen desto stabiler sind sie
ein schnell gedrehtes büros coop macht
deshalb absolut verrückte dinge auf den
tisch gestellt gibt es wie ein kreisel
einfach nicht um aber da wird noch nicht
das beste ich kann es auf eine spitze
stellen und es widersetzt sich der
gravitation die von der kavitation
verursachte schwerkraft kann das virus
coop einfach nicht aus seiner lage
bringen und an einem farben wird es noch
verrückter das teleskop spielt einfach
die physik auf den kopf so sein das tut
weh aber nicht wie wir jetzt wissen es
ist die unglaubliche trägheit die bei
schnellen preisbewegungen solche effekte
verursacht deshalb werden die büros
coop immer öfter in technischen
geräten eingesetzt phones können
dadurch die lage im raum erfassen kamera
stabilisierungssystem wie gimbel liegen
dadurch absolut stabil im raum oder der
tech welt fällt durch sie einfach nicht
wohl
so und jetzt die preise der sowie
preisen gibt es diese
cosmo bild experimentierkästen im wert
von rund 90 euro absolut cool damit
könnt ihr selber spielen programmieren
und konstruieren der absolute hammer und
das müsst ihr wissen um einen der
begehrten kästen gewinnen wie viele
videos habe ich hier auf klicks um seit
dem 17 januar inklusive diesem video
gemacht seitdem die videos nämlich
täglich die antwort ist aber nicht ganz
einfach also viel spaß beim fehlen
schreibt die antwort an klickst du
mail.com bei mehreren richtigen
antworten entscheidet das los wenn ihr
kein spannendes video von wiso mehr
verpassen wollt mir liegt ein abo vor
der kasten aufs auge und vergesst nicht
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
einer playlist mit allem videos seitdem
sitzen ja mal so hier viel spaß beim
anschauen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt auf jeden fall
dran